even a casual marvel fan will probably
know all about venom and they might know
a thing or two about carnage as well but
many other alien symbiotes have appeared
in the comics over the years here's the
lowdown on the biggest and baddest of
them all while trapped on another world
spider-man used an alien machine in
marvel superheroes secret wars number
eight to obtain a new black and white
costume after he returned to earth
however he discovered that his new
outfit was actually a living alien
symbiotic organism distraught peter used
the loud bell tower of a cathedral to
divorce himself from the symbiote but in
doing so he hand delivered it to a man
who would become one of his greatest
enemies eddie brock first introduced as
nothing more than a mysterious hand in
web of spider-man number 16 eddie was a
newspaper reporter who was blacklisted
when spider-man debunked his claims
about a local serial killer when peter
rejected the symbiote at the church
tower eddie was praying below and the
symbiote dropped down and bonded with
brock their mutual hatred for peter
united them and they became venom
i like being bad
it makes me happy
topher grace was the first actor to
portray a live-action venom in 2007
spider-man 3. although it's safe to
assume most fans prefer the tom hardy
incarnation who appeared in venom and
its sequel let there be carnage speaking
of whom
when eddie brock and the venom symbiote
were defeated and temporarily separated
eddie was imprisoned alongside a
notorious serial killer named cletus
cassidy the two didn't exactly get along
and when the venom symbiote finally came
back for eddie it spawned a new symbiote
one that bonded with cassidy at a
cellular level creating the monster
known as carnage carnage possesses all
the powers of venom but is stronger
faster and more durable additionally
because cassidy and carnage are bonded
at a cellular level they can't be
separated like venom and his many hosts
cassidy can simply reform carnage at
will with his newfound powers carnage
easily escaped from prison and began a
new killing spree he was only stopped
when venom and spider-man teamed up to
defeat him in amazing spider-man number
362 and 363. since then carnage has
returned time and time again to
terrorize the planet cletus cassidy made
his silver screen debut in the first
venom movie before returning as the main
antagonist in the sequel
that is a red one
right now
before 2018 riot was one of the most
obscure symbiotes in the marvel universe
in fact he didn't even get a name until
carnage usa number two in 2012 nearly a
decade after he was introduced but that
all changed when sony pictures decided
to use riot as the central antagonist in
venom
oh
feather that yeah the ugliest looking
thing i have ever seen
since then riot has become far more
popular with fans although the movie did
take some liberties with the character's
backstory in the film riot is the leader
of an advanced party sent to earth by
the klyntar species in order to prepare
for the symbiote invasion he bonded with
carlton drake the head of the sinister
life foundation and convinced him to
help bring the rest of the symbiotes to
earth in the comics the riot symbiote
wasn't a separate individual but instead
another of venom's many offspring riot
and four others were all created by
experimenting on the venom symbiote and
forcing it to reproduce five more times
introduced in amazing spider-man number
298 the life foundation was created to
ensure the richest and most powerful
people on earth could survive a nuclear
war by sheltering in their own personal
utopia to that end they sought out
creatures that could survive such a
world enter the klintar collectively
referred to as the life foundation
symbiotes riot phage agony lasher and
scream were all artificially created
from the original venom symbiote after
it was briefly captured phage initially
bonded with carl mock an officer of the
life foundation's private security force
when venom finally escaped his
imprisonment fage and his siblings were
sent to recapture him venom subsequently
teamed up with spider-man to fight the
life foundation symbiotes even though
they were badly outnumbered the duo
emerged victorious using a device that
seemingly aged each of them to dust
originally bonded with security officer
leslie jesneria agony was unique among
her life foundation siblings due to her
ability to deconstruct and create
chemical compounds she and her siblings
all survived brock's attempt to
disintegrate them largely thanks to the
life foundation's advanced technology
when the symbiotes began to gain more
control over their hosts bodies however
the five hosts revealed themselves to
eddie brock in the hopes that he would
teach them how to stay in charge eddie
refused believing that all of venom's
children would eventually become
psychopathic murderers like carnage
agony's sibling scream eventually proved
eddie's fears right and began
systematically killing off her other
siblings one by one after scream
believed all of her siblings were dead
she confronted eddie brock but was
defeated after a pretty brief fight
the outcast of the life foundation
symbiotes scream was originally bonded
with security officer donna diego a
woman with a history of schizophrenia
after she became scream she decided to
test out her abilities by attacking a
mall in california spider-man stopped
her assault and forced screamed to
retreat to the life foundation's
headquarters this allowed the webslinger
to follow her free venom and defeat the
five symbiotes though they survived the
experience sent to scream down a dark
path suffering from her schizophrenia
she attempted to kill her symbiote
siblings believing they would all
eventually be corrupted eventually
donald learned to cope with her mental
illness and came to an understanding
with her symbiote this allowed her to
operate as a hero for a short time she
helped venom defeat a number of foes but
was ultimately killed by eddie for the
same reason she had once used to justify
betraying her own siblings
originally merged with security officer
ramon hernandez the green symbiote known
as lasher fought alongside his life
foundation siblings until they were all
seemingly killed at the hands of scream
unknown to venom however the united
states government discovered that the
reports of their death were only half
true though the hosts had all died their
symbiotes had lived on and the us
government paired each to a different
member of the elite special ops military
team known as mercury team
where do all these guys come from
because the symbiotes were damaged from
their last encounter with eddie brock
they were each partially bonded to
augment one specific part of the host's
body riot was bonded with one member's
feet phage with another's hands and eyes
and agony with the last member's
shoulders lasher meanwhile was partially
bonded with both the team's leader
marcus sims and his german shepherd
forging a leash-like tether between the
pup and her master's hand though
effective the symbiote's new hosts were
eventually killed by carnage during one
of his many rampages
when riot phage agony and lasher
symbiotes were imprisoned within the
vault the government decided to
violently torture and experiment on them
in a secret lab beneath the facility
weakened by the experiments the four
symbiotes merged together to survive
when they were freed by a symbiote
invasion of earth together this new
hybrid was incredibly powerful
possessing each symbiote's unique
abilities free from its containment unit
the symbiote bonded with a prison guard
named scott washington and escaped
though initially just as cruel and
indifferent as the other guards once
they bonded with him scott realized how
much pain the creatures had experienced
this sudden epiphany of empathy changed
the pair for the better creating one of
the few true symbiote heroes ultimately
hybrid was killed by eddie brock when he
tried to exterminate every symbiote on
earth though the hybrid itself managed
to survive by separating into four
symbiotes once again scott himself was
not so lucky
cloned by the ararat corporation from a
severed piece of venom's tongue the
symbiote that would become known as
mania refused to permanently bond with
anyone instead choosing to kill and
consume everyone offered to it mania
eventually escaped its prison and
embarked on a killing spree across the
country until venom could finally
confront and absorb the symbiote back
into his biomass despite this mania
lived on within the venom symbiote
waiting to emerge once again when flash
thompson became agent venom for a time
he used his symbiote to shield a student
named andrea benton much to their
surprise however that piece of symbiote
bonded with the young girl and revealed
itself as mania flash helped andrea
control the symbiote and the two worked
together as heroes until a criminal
named lee price used sonic weapons to
steal the symbiote for himself with a
new host mania renamed himself to maniac
and began a short-lived crime empire
before being defeated by an alliance of
heroes led by spider-man
because they reproduce asexually each
symbiote can trace its lineage directly
back along one straight line venom was
the 998th
symbiote in this line and carnage was
the 999th
venom and carnage also knew that the
latter's offspring would be the 1000th
and believed that this symbiote would be
more powerful than the two of them
combined fearing this carnage attempted
to kill his offspring in venom vs
carnage number one but venom wanted to
raise the newborn as his villainous ally
giving it the name toxin ultimately both
villains failed when toxin bonded with a
new york city police officer named
patrick mulligan worried that this new
host would turn toxin into a superhero
venom and carnage teamed up in an
attempt to kill toxin but were
ultimately beaten by the 1 000th member
of their line despite this victory
patrick was constantly terrified that
the symbiote would take control and
become an unstoppable monster because of
this he fled from his family and
attempted to raise the young symbiote as
a hero his efforts were thwarted however
when the demon blackheart killed
mulligan and took toxin for his own ends
blackheart forced toxin to bond with
eddie brock and venom number 17 setting
the newly minted villain loose to kill
flash thompson in his agent venom
identity toxin was defeated however and
was left severely weakened as a shadow
of his former self
during a time when venom was separated
from eddie brock and bonded with matt
gargan eddie discovered that he had
cancer eddie was eventually healed but
the process completely altered the
traces of the venom symbiote that were
left within his cells because of this
when venom attempted to leave gargan and
reunite with eddie his cells rejected
the symbiote the portions of venom that
had touched him became the new separate
anti-venom symbiote anti-venom was the
villain's inverse in more ways than just
his color scheme the symbiote possessed
incredible healing powers that could be
used to rejuvenate his host or anyone
around him that healing ability led to
this version's death however when it
exhausted its life force to heal
manhattan of a spider virus a scientist
later used remnants of antivenom to
create a cure for venom's toxins but
when it was given to flash thompson in a
battle against eddie brock it didn't
cure anything at all instead it turned
the portion of venom attached to flesh
into a new anti-venom symbiote allowing
flash to become agent anti-venom
before the current cosmos were created
there was nothing but a void and its
name was null when the universe began
the nearly omnipotent celestials
attacked null and he created the first
symbiote in order to fight them off null
shaped the first symbiote into a blade
and used it to decapitate the celestial
driving the rest of them away inspired
by his success null created an army of
symbiotes and sent them out to conquer
the universe when they reached earth
however a young thor fought them off
because that's what heroes do
he infected the symbiotes with a sense
of honor that led them to unite against
null and imprisoned him seemingly
forever in their language klyntar meant
cage and by literally becoming null's
prison they became the klyntar race
eventually null corrupted scorn yet
another symbiote that originated from
carnage and used her to resurrect
carnage and free himself from his prison
the void god attempted to conquer all of
existence once again but was ultimately
killed by the combined might of earth's
heroes with a little help from eddie
brock check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about marvel comics are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]